alors le monde politique et les
canadiens ont appris aujourd'hui la mort
de jim flaherty une mort brusque
monsieur flight il ya un mois qui avait
laissé la vie politique pour aller
travailler dans le secteur privé qui
voulait être se rapprocher de ces trois
adolescents de sa famille et c'est avec
nous denis coderre on va bien sûr parler
du sujet de l'entrevue le sport à
montréal le grand prix le stade mais
d'abord vous avez siège est un fléau tic
beaucoup de gens ont souligné le fait
qu'il n'était pas partisan du crès il
était très humain avec tout le monde il
était humain c'est un guerrier
redoutable politicien redoutable mais
c'est un homme de quarante conviction
c'est quelqu'un qui évidemment pas
d'accord avec certains de ces dossiers
là comme si on a la mobilière une équipe
tout ça mais c'est quelqu'un qui croyant
ce qu'ils faisaient qui croyant son pays
puis je pense que de si vous avez eu
toute cette réaction beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion pourquoi pas c'était quelqu'un
qui était prêt près des gens on pouvait
on l'aimait pendant la période de
questions et puis on savait qu'on
tentait pour avoir des réponses suite
nous sommes peut-être sortes de choses
mais c'est sûr que tout le monde tout le
monde est très ému aujourd'hui vous
connaissez bien denis coderre la culture
à tahoua pour vivre neuf budgets
consécutifs durer comme ça faut être
fait fort faut être franc il passe à
travers la crise mondiale également et
je pense qu'une des raisons pourquoi on
a pu passer au travers cette à cause du
talent de james partie très bien alors
voilà pour jim flaherty aujourd'hui on
va écouter un très court extrait du
président du grand prix du canada
à soixante jours du grand prix 2014 il
ya urgence
oui à 60 jours de son édition 2014
malheureusement la pérennité du grand
prix du canada n'est pas encore assuré
françois dumontier hier donc qui lançait
un cri d'alarmé déjà au gouvernement
fédéral province et la ville parlez vous
c'est pas réglé où on négocie on est on
est à quelques semaines d'une d'une
signature entreprises premièrement on
accepter l'argent pour les
infrastructures donc on va investir dans
l'est les garages et tout ça pour d'ici
on a ils ont la copie du bail et laon
pour on doit être quand on doit être
conforme à la fédération internationale
automobile donc vous voyez tout le monde
les documents tout le monde se parle et
puis je pense que c'est correct de
mettre de la pression comme ça mais
monsieur du monde c'est mons parle
continuellement de toute façon puis tout
le monde se parle pire on veut créer un
grand prix à montréal pour votre ipod
donc j'étais convaincu que le grand la
signature pour les 10 prochaines
éditions
c'est réglé si c'est pas le maire de
montréal qui va être fait pour moi qui
faisais je suis mémorial où on a perdu
notre grand prix parce que les chiffres
sont connus ne sait pas que monsieur
kraus on demande plus c'est 15 millions
par année ses 40 millions pour
l'investissement pour moderniser le site
la question qui fait c'est comme à qui
va payer c'est toujours la question des
redevances à question de partage mais
tout le monde est haut et tout le monde
s'en ligne on veut on veut s'assurer que
ça fonctionne payer ça va fonctionner
mais il faut comprendre que faut agir de
façon responsable c'est quand même une
entente de 10 ans est ce que ça sera
signé avant l'édition de cette année mon
jour mon choix que ça se fasse très
rapidement mener à bien ce qu'ont pu
s'élancer avant très bien le toit du
stade
monsieur le maire là c'était hier la
coupe grey qui nous on aimerait
peut-être à venir à montréal et pas
question qu'on peut devenir s'il n'y a
pas de toi da combien de temps vous
qu'est ce que vous demandez à québec
précisé comme j'ai dit pendant la
campagne électorale pour lui quand même
des réponses dont du premier ministre où
qu'il se fasse donc on prenne la
décision de le faire
en disant oui donc avec cette volonté
politique c'est un processus qui va
prendre au moins cinq dont il faut
prendre une décision maintenant c'est
c'est un investissement important parce
que non seulement une structure
architecturale extraordinaire mais avec
la façon dont on ne refait toute la
mission du parc olympique avec les
événements vous avez vu les les
les maîtres contre les jays x assure 950
jours d'événements ont cette toile vont
être rentable de toute façon puis pour
moi je pense qu'il faut faire
on peut pas le faire avant 5 non parce
qu'il faut que ça il faut le défendre et
tout ça donc c'est sûr que ce ne sera
pas forcément quasiment plus vite que ça
on travaille sur le pont aussi social au
dossier en 2010 c'est ce que monsieur
labrecque audi alors même si michel
labrecque au dic c'est ce que ça prend
mais vous ça prend des décisions
maintenant puis mais ce que je comprends
monsieur couillard est d'accord avec ça
est ce que vous vous croyez dur comme
fer au potentiel du parc dit oui
totalement il ya un avenir pour le
parquet
regardez l'espace pour la vie le
planétarium le stade saputo
des événements comme les no future expo
alors vous avez des événements on peut
emmener au sud est du soccer à montréal
si on veut avoir le mondial
éventuellement c'est une structure
extraordinaire et c'est l'endroit qui
est le plus visité à montréal ça fait
partie de notre signature on va arrêter
de dire bon c'est pas bon c'est pas bon
c'est bon qu'on le fasse que toi une
fois pour toute c'est un investissement
et on va pouvoir travailler en
conception vous donnait le choix entre
nouveau stade de baseball au
centre-ville de montréal et de
moderniser le vieux stade est ce que je
peux vous souffrez on peut faire les
deux sauf ces pôles 6 5 1 tout le
travail ces deux dossiers qui est
complètement différent on veut voir ce
que le secteur privé puisse embarquer il
faut y aller de façon responsable la
population et la faux évidemment
s'assurer que tout se fait dans les
règles négocier avec la ligue de
baseball majeur mon n'est pas posée tout
d'un coup qu'on a une équipe on peut
dire on veut une équipe on va travailler
en conséquence notre façon responsable
mais en même temps il ya un avenir pour
ce stade dont vous y croyez vous à ce
rêve du retour du baseball majeur le
mâle vous étirer aller
après avoir parlé à tout ce monde là
tout le monde est à côté d'eux mais
c'était surtout de ses deux matches là
ce n'est pas de la nostalgie
c'était familial plusieurs générations
c'est pas tout ce qu'on véhicule
le pack jarry là vous aviez des jeunes
qui avaient jamais vu les expos il y
avait un enthousiasme épouvantable
s'était rempli cent mille personnes
c'est quelque chose alors pour moi c'est
clair que montréal est une ville le
baseball est une ville d'événement est
une ville de sport professionnel est ce
que vous allez vous battre comme le
maire de québec pour son amphithéâtre
vous pour ces deux gros projets là le
toit et un nouveau show
je veux travailler pour la rigolade mais
une volonté politique que je sens puis
on va parler rapidement pour la question
du baseball ya des étapes à suivre je
l'avais expliqué l'autre fois là il ya
eu l'étude de faisabilité
le monsieur météo de juniors qui sont
pas qui était montréal est d'ailleurs
l'ancien président des expos et elle a
été impressionnée on négociera pas sur
la place publique on va s'assurer que
des investisseurs qui veulent venir et
par la suite on a un rôle à jouer nous
comme gouvernement société et vous
l'avez dit très rapidement mais je veux
le soumis avant dernier vous vous avez
encore le rêve du mondial à montréal en
2021 montréal est une métropole
extraordinaire moi comme ministre des
sports la dernière entente que j'ai
signé 7 avec joseph blatter de la fifa
est maintenant plus hockey canada est
d'accord les la mls et de canadiennes
est d'accord vous avez joey saputo qui
est totalement d'accord avec ça faut
travailler ensemble et puis montréal et
toucy et le canada est maintenant un
pays de sault quel est ce que en
félicitant le nouveau premier ministre
élu monsieur coup hier vous avez dit
monsieur quia jeune inspecteur général à
la ville dont il manque des pouvoirs
parce qu'il n'ya pas de loi encore
est-ce que ça s'en vient d'après ce coup
ci je peux vous offre un primeur il ya
une heure et demie à peine je parle avec
monsieur couillard on s'est entendus dès
ce printemps il va avoir le dépôt de la
loi donc priorité priorité c'est ça fait
partie des priorités du gouvernement
on ne rit que j'ai encore on a réitéré
que dès ce printemps
on a réitéré le statut de métropole et
puis tout ce que l'on sait c'est
vraiment montréal
va pouvoir obtenir ce qu'il désire denis
coderre merci beaucoup
alors on a devancé événements sportifs
l'avons vraiment se matérialiser à
montréal une volonté un commerçant et
merci à lui à voir